[Music]
today we're presenting on real-time
streaming applications on GCP so I'm
going to present with my colleague at
Kailash Singh so we're both from Sydney
from the JPAC professional services team
and I clash is the lead strategic cloud
engineer and I am the I'm a cloud
consultant in data and analytics so we
work on this stuff every day so
hopefully we're will share a little bit
of what we've learnt with you so those
three things we're going to cover the
first is why Google cloud then I'll talk
about what we have to offer our Google
cloud and the different Suites of
product like the different products that
are available to do streaming real-time
applications and then I'll go through
how you would do it
and then after that we've got a demo and
there's a chance to win we have some
three prizes so we're gonna get some
interactivity going and at that point
I'm gonna ask you to pull out your
phones so if everyone wants to get your
internet connection ready that would be
good so let's start with why so big data
is in our DNA at Google we have over
eight products with over so we have
eight products with over 1 billion users
so a lot of the products that were
making available through to you to do
these types of problems to solve these
problems are things that we use
internally and that we've made available
to the community so this was started in
2002 where we've been innovating on lots
of different products so you might have
heard of big table or spanner and a lot
of these innovations were made available
to the open source community and so what
we're now doing is then bringing those
back to Google platform and open and
making them available as services as
managed services to you so things like
bigquery and pub/sub and
bigtable are all services that we
provide so our focus for the customer is
to focus on insights so rather than you
having to worry about the infrastructure
letting you focus on what you want to do
with the data and get the insights out
is our key focus another is looking at
streaming analytics so being able to get
real-time business insights and make a
business more responsive so if you can
get insights in in real time then you
can also react in real time and then we
make that easier to do using machine
learning so what you can do is once
you've got your data coming in real time
a player machine learning algorithm on
top of it and actually make it
actionable automatically without you
having to manually intervene so I'll
talk about what next so what's available
on Google cloud platform to do streaming
analytics and streaming up us so we we
focus on four stages of a data platform
so the first is the ability to ingest at
any scale so what we're going to show
you today is actually not that we can do
streaming but that we can do it at scale
so we're gonna have the ability to
adjust thousands and millions of
messages the second is to process and
transform the data reliably the third is
to store seamlessly and the fourth is to
analyze learn and validate I'm sorry and
visualize with speed so we're gonna go
through each one of these and I'm going
to talk to you all the Google Club
platform products that enable each of
these so that brings me to the hell so
this is a typical data pipeline that I'm
gonna walk through and we have lots of
different ways of doing things so this
is just sort of one way of facing things
together but it's quite a common
architecture so we start with streaming
events coming in like from IOT devices
or in this case we're actually gonna
have mobile device data that's coming in
and that will be read to a cloud sorry
written to a cloud pub/sub topic imma
get we can read from that cloud pub/sub
topic
as well so cloud pub/sub is a service
fully managed asynchronous messaging
platform so basically it's pretty
straightforward you just publish the top
you can read from it the second is we
can also ingest batch data so you can
actually do both of those at the same
time so data flow which is going to be
the next step is gonna is going to be
able to handle both those types of
streams of data sources story and that
is going to be read into cloud storage
which is performing unified and
cost-effective object storage bucket for
a binary and blob data so then it's
going to go into cloud dataflow the data
flow has connectors to pub/sub and to
cloud storage and it's going to be able
to process our data and apply
transformations as we need them to to
Batchelor stream so one interesting
thing about dataflow is that we can't
handle real-time streaming data so we
can apply things something you do
differently to batch data is you apply
things like windowing functions where
you take an aggregate of the data that's
being right in and you can and you pass
that downstream but we can also use
other products like data proc so if you
have already got sparkin who new jobs
you can migrate them over to data proc
and we can then from dataflow write it
out to bigquery or BigTable so you can
go to lots of different sources this is
just an example so big careers our data
warehousing solution and BigTable is our
high-performance new sequel database to
large workloads well and then we can
apply machine learning on top of that so
once the data is in a database we can
pull it out or you can actually use it
directly from data flow and then we have
a lot of visualization options and
different analytical tools so we can use
cloud data lab which is a Jupiter
notebooks type of environment you can
use either third-party tools or
something like data studio which is a bi
tool that we have you can share with
other people or you can produce
applications reports so we've done the
last one today as well as we can show
you that
okay so we're about ready to start the
competition so can I ask everyone if
you're if you want to participate get
your phones out right now and get a web
browser open and we're gonna give you a
URL in a minute so you can get that
ready these are the prizes just to give
you a little bit of an incentive so we
have a pair of Google cloud socks a
beanie and a t-shirt so what we're gonna
do is you're gonna vote and the highest
score will win one of these prizes every
TI flesh so this is the URL we need to
go to and you will see a very simple
voting application with only three logos
you can't go wrong there just enter your
username and start voting so if
everything goes well you'll see your
name mapping appearing here
Akhilesh probably just leave the URL
yeah
okay so we're gonna set a timer and
we'll bring the URL back out and you'll
have one minute so go back to the URL
page - sorry can you bring up the URL
but yep so it is a bit dolly flash 2w r
IV b p and the IV PE b is lowercase cool
so try and fight as many times as you
can or each of the products you might
want to pick one that you really like
click the socks all the hot the beanie
and then in about a minute one down can
you get the timer up Akhilesh cool so I
push wall that's going do you mind
explaining what's happening in the
backend yeah so in real time when we
when you're placing a button the request
is going to App Engine instance and App
Engine scales automatically you don't
have to scale it so we were actually not
running any instances but because of the
voting application we will see that
there will be many application instances
which will be created on the fly on the
other side of things there's this data
flow which Liz talked about and in data
flow what happens is like when the
messages are in the copper queue on the
puff sub-q it reads from there and as
you can see it's processing huge number
of misses without any scaling who's that
the results are actually presented here
so you can see like the ninja is winning
as of now for socks and with a total of
15 votes and this is updating in real
time as you click on the button slide
yeah are we nearly done yeah we fourteen
seconds away
whoa okay ten ten seconds
five four three two one
I should take a screenshot yeah so
whoever is listed at the top now after
the session please come over to the
experiment pod one and we'll give you
your prize yes so we'll take a second to
just let it refresh and we declare the
winners cool so this is not the end of
it like when you build a really cool app
it may actually become very popular
across the globe and not only hundred
but let's say like there are millions of
users so I'm using a tool which is
jmeter it's a bare-bones emitter which
can create millions of requests on our
server and we start saying that we are
encountering zero percent error and the
number of requests is this so there's
already three thousand requests which
has been passed in a short duration of
time and let's see if it reflects on the
e that's good so as you see like this is
completely it's serving a solution it
relies on components which will let's
talk about this App Engine and this data
flow they scale all well without a say
without any developer intervention
cool so I'm just gonna talk through what
we just did
just to recap so can you skip both sorry
I'll do it
so what we did was we read real-time
events in from your mobile devices using
an app engine front-end so that's
actually scaling up to meet the demand
so however many people here who I was
logging on at this time we're scaling up
and then when Akhilesh just showed you
that last screen what he was doing was
injecting a lot of extra events from a
robot now that's been read in through
cloud pub/sub so it's been published to
a topic and we're reading that back
through from debt cloud dataflow so
cloud dataflow is taking those messages
and processing them in parallel in real
time with latency of just a couple of
seconds and publish them to bigquery and
from bigquery we're presenting that
dashboard on the screen which is showing
you the leaderboard so we've managed to
piece together end to end and then we
can also do a few more things which we
we didn't do in this presentation but
it's just to demonstrate as well that
you can actually get batch data at the
same time and you can actually process
both battery streaming data together
with cloud dataflow or separately if you
wish and then output it to lots of
different options of destinations
so just to recap there's a couple of big
customers that are using solutions like
this so we have twitter who is using it
to help them scale so they've got her to
a hybrid hadoop in data probe cluster
and they're working towards the sub
fully service environment or google
cloud we have air asia with 500 million
passengers they're using bigquery
pub/sub data studio and they've been
able to reduce their costs using those
tools and we have Spotify who are cloud
native and have you know implemented
these solutions to help them so the key
takeaway today is that the focus is on
real-time insects so we have these
massive amounts of data coming in and we
want to be able to make use of them in
real time make decisions in real time
and add values your business in real
time
so thank you very much
[Music]